[Music]
On January 5th 2012 a group calling
itself 3301 posted a mysterious message
on the Internet
Wow we are looking for highly
intelligent individuals to find them we
have devised a test there is a message
hidden in this image the hidden message
led to a series of other riddles codes
leading to phone messages which provided
GPS coordinates for posters around the
world a mysterious group has been
posting extremely complicated puzzles on
the Internet solving the puzzles
requires some esoteric knowledge
computer programming hidden codes
history art and literature as obscure as
medieval Welsh poetry the puzzle was
called cicada and appeared to be a
recruiting tool for a secretive
organization that called itself 3301 I
was obsessed it was just all cicada all
the time I didn't sleep a whole lot I
was basically just holed up in my room I
really wanted to find the answer in
January 2013 a new cicada puzzle
appeared with more elaborate clues
surrounding cicada with even more
intrigue there was not a class that went
by and not a shift of work that I didn't
have my laptop it was my life no one
knew who created the puzzles or what
their intentions were I wasn't sure if
it was like a government recruitment or
some underground hacking group I'm torn
fandoms support and soon cicada became
one of the greatest mysteries of the
internet this is hugely elaborate it's a
very very involved game
[Music]
in 2014 the puzzle reached its height of
complexity with a book of encrypted
symbols called the libra Primus it's 58
pages long
two of them are solved to this day the
contents of the rest are a complete
mystery believer Primus it's encrypted
which obscures the original message
right and the search space itself for
like the possible messages that it could
be is nearly infinity the libra Primus
was so hard
most people just gave up but a small
group of amateur puzzle solvers from
around the world banded together and
refused to quit there's no one person
who's going to be better than a giant
group of like-minded individuals working
together we have never had a puzzle that
we took that much time to solve and
still could not do it we can get into
these zones where we focus on one thing
so intensely and we become consumed by
it other people might consider it an
obsession but to us this is perfectly
normal I would ever explain cicada in
just one sentence it's a puzzle after a
puzzle after a puzzle
presumably leading to some payoff even
when you get to have a payoff you are
left wondering what exactly just
happened to you
Viki has always been right in front of
your eyes good luck three three zero one
I'm Bryan Burrough I've been an
investigative journalist for 35 years
I've taken on mysteries the large and
small all over the world New York
Hollywood Tokyo Jerusalem Kathmandu
there very few major mysteries in the
world that ever say mysteries forever
cicada it's out there and it's an
unknown what is this thing why is this
thing who is this thing
[Music]
these individuals from all over the
planet have been working on cicada
puzzles since 2012 I am dying to know
what makes them tick what drives them on
this almost Sisyphean task that is it
cicada 3301 they've spent three years
trying to find an answer to the libra
Primus and members of the group are
still searching now we think it could be
[Music]
[Laughter]
they are convinced a solution is out
there they're still hopeful because one
of them actually solved the first puzzle
back in 2012 and got further into the
world of cicada than anyone before since
and he was only 15 years old at the time
I'm Marcus Warner and I'm one of the
people who solved the original cicada
puzzle in 2012 I was yeah just about
your average 15 year old kid so I grew
up in rural South West Virginia I didn't
feel like I really had a whole lot of
friends because I was home-schooled yeah
I missed out on a few things
but most of it came down to like
bullcrap high school relationships and
bullcrap middle school drama I had a lot
of free time playing around and
exploring stuff and I was always really
curious but what I was actually doing
was building a career by accident
my dad was an electrical engineer and he
just like showed me how to solder and
stuff
I spent about two or three years frying
every single electronic component that I
touched because I didn't understand what
they did used to make fireworks little
bombs and stuff we made a mortar the
shot tennis balls around one time you
take a bunch of Pringles tubes and duct
tape fill it up with a little gasoline
and you like the gas fumes and suddenly
you're kind of spoiled in the neighbors
here I like to use technology to solve
interesting problems and do things that
you wouldn't normally be able to do
[Music]
I was just hanging out on 4chan one
Saturday night because that's what pom
school kids do there's a lot of really
disturbing content on there it's
definitely not a place where you take
everything that's said at face value
because nobody has like a name attached
to them I was on the science and math
board I saw the three 301 image
recruiting people and I'm like well how
would I hide data in this image
there was an IRC server link in the
thread that was on the board it's an
online chatroom right IRC we had two or
three messages a second that were
popping up in this chatroom
it's scrolling faster than you can read
it I don't think I slept that night what
they had done is just taken Lane text
and stuck it on the end of the files it
was pretty easy to tell that it was a
URL because it was one letter two of the
same letter two different letters and
then two of the same thing which is you
know HTTP colon slash slash she get the
idea we got to the URL and it was
actually a duck we were supposed to take
in his words we'll see if you can guess
how to get the message out they
recognized out and guess and we're like
oh how it gets out guess is just a tool
that you can use to hide text inside of
a JPEG image they're meant to be
impossible to detect like that's the
idea of steganography or hiding messages
inside of other messages but the ste go
stuff is more like if you went into a
room with a china cabinet and you
rearranged the china and the cabinet
slightly like blue cup is on the third
shelf to signal a message ste go tools
like out guests it's like just trying a
bunch of different ways of interpreting
the china cabinet
so you find one where our message falls
out
after we did the out guess it started
giving us a phone number we were like oh
fun um BRR that's weird
we had no idea what to expect at that
point very good you have done well there
are three prime numbers associated with
the original final dot JPEG image three
three zero one is one of them you will
have to find the other two it was just a
generic phone number we tried to pull
the records on it some people try to
social engineers some folks who work
there and it turns out that their
customer support people couldn't
actually access the records for that
particular number and I thought that was
kind of weird well supply all three of
these numbers together and edicom on the
end to find the next day good luck
so cicada told us that there were three
prime numbers in the original message
that we had started with first one was 3
301 but the other two are a little bit
harder to find they were just the
dimensions of the image so we multiplied
them and we got this comma dress it was
just a plain white website with a cicada
on it and a countdown timer to like a
day or two in the future once the
countdown was over they posted all of
these coordinates in different places
across the world Moscow Sydney Seoul
they've got a better at there it was
taped you can see the corner today
suddenly it's not we just need to solve
this puzzle it looks the same on
everybody screens who gives a [ __ ] where
we are we started reaching out to people
and like actually figuring out where
everybody was and that was how we found
out some of us live near each other and
sort of laid the groundwork for the the
community that's sprung up ever since
[Music]
so the QR code led us to Agrippa
a science-fiction author named William
Gibson created this agrippa poem that
was both printed in a book where the
pages would dissolve when exposed to air
and also on a floppy drive that would
erase itself after printing out the text
of the book once it just disappears but
we were able to get a copy of it
a few weeks later we got a signed and
encrypted email from 3301 we are not in
hacker group
cicada said overtly that they weren't
into doing any illegal stuff we have
that you thief and desist all illegal
activity they said that they were
something like a think tank hobbyists
volunteer type of an organization
there's one last and we expect you to be
honest with us
they said we were ready for the next
step but we had to answer some questions
first there are questions about digital
liberty freedom of information some
ideological things that they were
working towards as one of their
organization's goals I replied to the
email with all of those answers and then
I just had to sit and wait
[Music]
after a month I found out I was a member
of cicada
Marcus and I have been friends since
before the cicada years it was him who
convinced me to come and try it out
he's certainly by far one of the
smartest people I know we met on IRC
actually Marcus tonight on January 6
2013 cicada tweeted out a second major
puzzle it attracted many new would-be
solvers when a Foom goes by the name NOx
Populi
I'm NOx popula I'm 28 years old I'm from
Alberta it's a prairie provinces me to
love Canada middle of nowhere really
there is nothing in ours in every
direction from here it is just empty
Plains out forever and I mean the city
sort of reflects it I have a full-time
job I do these cryptography puzzles in
my free time I have a youtube series on
cicada hello and welcome to part 1 of my
2013's akkada 3301 series the whole
point of this youtube channel i set up
was there's one big attempt to explain
this to a layperson Soffer go to file a
new certificate we can make our own
identity here I'm terrible at coming up
with user names like they're all bad NOx
Populi I had actually never intended
anyone to hear that username I was
listening to a song called Vox Populi
which is that Latin term voice of the
people at the time my girlfriend's cat
was named NOx and he had trapped himself
under a bowl under my desk and was like
bumping into my feet and meowing so I
was just the two things I had at the
time I just threw together and moved on
let's be honest I'm gonna sleep put my
phone on max volume so if it comes up
like 4:00 in the morning someone just
wake me up I'll get on here it doesn't
matter all right I'm gonna head
they're sort of like three levels of the
community if you go just up to the
general internet the number of people
interested in cicada is ridiculously
large there is things like Facebook
groups
there's the wiki massive amounts of
people but most of those people never
actually worked on cicada they're just
kind of interested in it then you kind
of take a step closer in and there's the
IRC communities that's more looking to
work on something but even that that's a
massive group
[Music]
when you're actually working on cicada
you pick the few people you know you're
good at working with because you're
really going to be doing this at
insanely fast pace and you also need to
be sure you can trust that if they make
a discovery they're not just gonna run
off without you that sort of thing
[Music]
you got this step in 2013 every time you
take another piece of it off there's
just more and more complexity
you got this link it takes you to this
Dropbox
it's just a Dropbox links to a file and
there's no extension on the file it ends
up being this disk image so what you
would do is boot from that instead of
your operating system it's an operating
system on its own so it's sort of like
the cicada OS that you're loading in Co
on your computer which is actually a
kind of terrifying that's got the whole
like Linux file structure dig around in
there and that's where the song first
comes from just sitting in one of the
tama folders it was called 761 mp3 if
you start looking into all the different
tags on it it was called the instruments
kind of classical guitar at first and
then starts kind of getting weirder and
weirder
there's this unique composed piece of
music just for the few people would ever
find it on this disc
the further we went into the puzzle the
more obscure the clues became a Mayan
numerals early-1900s
occult stuff Aleister Crowley sent
Buddhist futhark ruins every time you
move anywhere in cicada all of the other
layers about just first open an
exceptional amount of work has gone into
making all of these individual tiny
pieces meticulously fit together it's
like opening the face of your watch for
the first time you have no concept of
how all of those gears somehow work into
seconds minutes and hours but suddenly
you can see the scope of it and it's
staggering finally you get to this
website and it starts a timer and starts
putting questions up on screen the large
part of it was multiple choice my
favorite one is everyone understands
what you mean when you say it's dark
outside
what does it refer to in the previous
sentence they might have an answer they
might not it's trying to make you think
it's sort of like all the Zen jokes
about a sound of one hand clapping
there's not really a good explanation
for what's happening but the timer's
going
very good to attain enlightenment create
a GPG key for your email address
so it got the invitation I sent back my
response I was so excited and then was
waiting days turned into weeks no
response
nothing ever came
On January 5th 2014 cicada released its
third major puzzle a series of steps
that led to a 58 page book of symbols
they called it the libra Primus as 58
pages in a language you don't speak
it's insane staggering
we had no starting point we don't know
if it's steganography it could have been
anything there's no individual person
knows enough to even start tackling it
alone because it's just there's too many
options any one person could work on it
the rest of their lives
and probably not going to half way no
one particularly stood out until one
cool he was consistently putting out
ideas no one else had and work that
should have been done and no one else
was doing
I'm actually gonna show you guys
something look at this I believe that
this message is is a hint seeking you'll
be found yeah okay Libra Primus is the
way I think this is then saying you guys
sought to solve this before anything
else happen I think what you were
getting at one cool is Libra Primus is
the way because of this message
[Music]
[Laughter]
one cool there's not much of a story
behind it other than the movie hackers
he was zero cool was the first like
movie I ever had on my computer and I
watched it and I loved it my brother was
like you should be one cool that's like
all right I've been one cool since mid
2000 something growing up in a small
town in Nebraska it had about a thousand
people we lived pretty close to the
train tracks and then right across the
train tracks is kind of just like
nothing it was in 4h and we would raise
these calves feed them brush them wacom
you train them to like walk circles and
be nice-looking animals growing up in
the town I wasn't a popular kid or
anything that is when I really got into
computers because I was just like I
don't my friends then I like found my
computer friends in the middle in high
school my mom wouldn't pay for this game
monthly so I had to learn how to host my
own server with it and like set it all
up and just trying to solve these
problems so I could have fun with my
brothers I went to college for Computer
Engineering and my Master's mathematics
I work in the field of cryptography
cryptography is technically ammunition
it's huge valuable tool in war so my
knowledge of this cryptography it
classifies me as a weapon so something
like a walking missile
when I first saw the Libra Primus I did
I wasn't sure if we were gonna be able
to solve it they introduced the
difficulty of not using English so that
itself raised the bar right away to be
like well you can't just like type this
out on your keyboard you have to like
transcribe each one of these old Nordic
runes I spent many nights transcribing a
letter by letter so there's a lot to the
Libra Primus it seems like the more time
we spend on it the more little oddities
we find one of the pages was not
encrypted it was only written in runic
so it was a matter of substituting a
room for the English letters so that was
easy
another page was encrypted with the
stream of numbers so the result of
solving the second to last page was a
message that said we had to seek out a
page on the Deep Web
they said it's everybody's due to eat to
find this page the number of
possibilities for what content might be
in the Libra Primus like if all Nebraska
was buried in six feet of hay and
there's a single needle gotta like come
up with some way to find that and yeah
that's the difficulty so I did some
stuff today when I could fit it around
my other shed working a puzzles I've
learned a lot I've done a lot of cool
people I've also been like this thinking
about a lot of [ __ ] which I can want to
talk about our process later on
yeah Knox is our Canadian he kinda just
keeps us going meeting coming up with
ideas trying them out and keeping track
of them and keeping track of each other
one cool did you have anything you could
say
I never made it into the spark program
in school hilarious hundred percent
convinced were smarter than me brother
box was really engaged in the community
he started in the cicada solvers IRC and
likes done a lot of programming and
helped us with like image analysis this
makes no sense to me what cool are you
[ __ ] serious
that's not how you I love brother box
like I think I understand his
personality I think it's a very caring
person but he also can be like a total
[ __ ] how about you like put the
answer and then encrypted message and
then I'll have to break it I I gotta say
right now our track record for breaking
encrypted messages isn't so good of
shadow-walker she's really good I like
keeping track of things and teaching
people and no shadow-walker
yeah I think she's great to work with I
can actually run our words
whit's tag detect that's never you
should be great yeah that's a good call
she lives in the Middle East I know it's
kind of rough and she has more in danger
like she has to keep things encrypted
and under the radar when you guys just
get this done like cancel my just like
send me a PM so I can take a look at it
when I wake up power markets are you
back I will around I can identify
characters really cool that's awesome
Marcus is fun great with the crypto he
doesn't like the rooms you like
steganography kind of thing this is all
the black dots each of these little
clusters up here holy [ __ ] I think it's
a fun way to spend part of your life
like working on some hard problem with
people you know I do believe that we
have the most coordination of any people
that is right this I would consider in
this group like confront alone okay well
I think that's a that's a good list for
what we do
bye guys talk to you later bye
oh my gosh
that's an Enigma machine we've really
been stuck if you weren't persistent you
wouldn't be attacking ciphers we can't
drop the problem you want to see the
salt I could tell you got the fire
governments are increasingly efficient
at surveilling their people and this
will only get worse in my mind I feel
like the flow of information in this
society should always be free the
project we ended up working on was
intended to solve a life and death
problem for people who have reason to
fear for their lives someone parked a
van outside of my house so this is the
back Jesus Christ
it's areia NSA is a big place could one
of our folks conceivably have done it
that is a very tricky ethical legal
moral question answer it's a kid I
believe if they could sow a little seed
of curiosity into the minds of people
[Music]
[Music]